if somebody said to you okay we are
clearly
moving into a bear market
how long do you think it will last i
think that the fed's
trade-off
between inflation and growth it always
tricks to see a balance and there are
some times when conditions are good
usually when there's not much debt
that that trade-off is not difficult to
run we're entering a period of time
where there's an inflationary
great inflationary pressure
due to the fact that you produce so much
money and
and at the same time they're trying to
strike that balance of the tightening of
monetary policy so it looks to me like
an environment like a stagflation kind
of environment where both will be a
particular challenge so individuals have
got to know what does that mean for
example interest rates and debt
instruments that they're holding will
not have a real return they have that's
adequate that in other words not enough
earnings to make uh compensate for
inflation last year we had an inflation
rate of about eight percent there's a
zero earnings so if people start to
think in terms of buying power and
realize that cash instruments and and
debt instruments are going to be a
challenge and try to diversify their
portfolios those would be the main
headlines that i'd convey in terms of
don't just look at up and down and bull
markets and bear markets look at
diversification and be very particularly
worried about uh whether the real
returns that you're going to get on your
cash or your bonds i think too many
people are not worried about that kind
of environment if you're if you even
study the 70s or other periods of time
like that that would be helpful